is lizzo beautiful
she has a beautiful personality
Urban Beauty we're saying it's okay to
be unhealthy I'm just being completely
honest I know she's very happy with who
she is more power to her but don't set
up a societal world where you're saying
basically it's okay to not care about
yourself
sorry but it's true I know we all think
it and I will say it but it's [__]
true we need to care more about your
internal health we need to care more
about how we feel unless we all want to
have type 2 diabetes in 10 years I
really genuinely don't so
it's important to care about yourself
Jessica's lizzo beautiful
I don't know who's that lizzo the singer
the big lady
everybody's praising her nowadays she's
so beautiful she's so empowered
I don't really look at Lots no problem
uh Nicole this is Elizabeth beautiful
it doesn't matter or what I think
because I'm not in the socio-sexual
market for women so it really only
matters with the men in the market think
of lizzo if she wants to be with men so
I don't see why my comment on her
appearance would even matter maybe I
should rephrase it is is women telling
her that she's beautiful a good idea
like is it a is it a healthy statement
to make
I think it's fine if Liz's girlfriends
tell her she's beautiful you know it's
interesting I'm not commenting on her
value in the socio-sexual market with
men but that's up to lizzo and Men
it's you know it's interesting because
if you were to ask somebody if they
think that lizzo is beautiful and they
say yes
try this next time they say this and say
you know you kind of look like lizzo
and see what they do with that
see if they really think that she's
beautiful so yeah like I just want to
ask that question to see how you know
you guys would deal with
um you know women complimenting other
women like one of the things you said uh
earlier Nicole is that you not only hold
men to standards but you want to hold
women or standards but you didn't have
an opinion when I asked you about lizos
I just want to sort of
I'm like what do you think about that
should should hold herself to a healthy
weight to like a healthy standard of
weights I think that they have diabetes
and things like that I think that for me
to comment on other women especially in
this context is irrelevant but for
myself I hold myself to a standard as a
woman and there are different health
goals goals spiritually physically
emotionally psychologically that I want
for myself and so I'm going to do that
but if but I'm not going to tell lizzo
or anyone they should or shouldn't do
XYZ and this whole Market that we're
talking about will is whatever it is
um but I don't
lizzo should do and not do you know what
she wants that's her choice and I'll
make my choices
we aren't allowed to have
to have feelings all of a sudden you're
canceled you're either racist homophobic
all that crap so us even saying anything
about lizzo I can guarantee is in some
ways stay or form affecting someone
because for some reason the First
Amendment isn't a thing anymore but
moth made a comment about if you have
this you can do this and be this but I
think it's super important and I learned
this be do you have instead of have Judy
before you learn that
I learned it at the Hoffman Institute I
want in this Wellness Retreat and truly
it changed my whole life but be who you
want to be do it what you want to do and
have what you and truly I have been
thinking that way lately
yeah for those of you that
yeah for those of you that might be
interested I have a video on my
entrepreneurs and cars channel from
several years ago where I was talking
about be do you have
um it really aligns your mindset with uh
goals and getting things done that
reflects what it is that you want to get
in life next question for you guys last
question actually
um do you think that marriage today is a
good idea
and why
who said no Amber I said no and it's
crazy because I always wanted to get
married I have like everything I ever
wanted to dress the venue everything but
I just feel like at this time and age
with
I'm not even talking about the values
and the relationship how laws are in
different states when it comes to
marriage how people act there's like
everything that's so hard nowadays like
I have a friend going through a divorce
in California
she was a breadwinner she provided
everything for this man and now because
of the halls in California have to give
half first off to this random dude so it
sucks but honestly I just feel like it's
more important to Value yourself find a
traditional relationship or be with a
man you love like my aunt my uncle they
aren't married they've been together for
15 years and they're the most happy
couple I've ever seen do they live
together no they live separately but
they spend pretty much every single day
together it's crazy I know it's so weird
but for some reason it works for them
and it's always worked out since I was a
little kid it's been like 20 years I
think I don't know I think so that's my
years almost all right uh Shania do you
think marriage is a good idea today
it's kind of a tough question to ask
because I'm kind of like Amber like I'm
such a hopeless romantic I love the idea
of marriage but when it comes down to
the logistics of it I don't believe it's
a good idea right now in this day and
age
um I would love love to be married but I
don't think it's it's a smart idea at
the moment why is it not a smart idea
for you
uh for me personally or for anyone well
in your opinion well yeah
um I mean divorce rate is just still
pretty high I mean it's always been high
but with the
um
what's the word I want the availability
with dating apps and social media and
Temptation I think it's kind of
Amplified
um so you know back in the day you know
you got married and you know you
probably got married to someone that you
met in town in person and all that
nowadays you can talk to someone in
Europe you can talk to someone in
Australia you can talk to so you know
there's so much availability so it's
kind of hard to be
married when there is so much out there
if that makes sense like maybe that's
just my trust issues coming out but at
the same time I'm just like I just I
don't know just to clarify like you're
worried about your partner being tempted
not you personally
okay you're worried about whoever you
would end up with being tempted and
going and leaving you for someone else
well not even that too I might be doing
a hard bad job of explaining it but like
for example if I got married and my
husband and I got in a fight you know
what's the first thing someone's gonna
do is be like well there's there's gonna
be someone else I'll just go and talk
someone else because it's so available
so it's kind of I feel like the value of
marriage is
that's the big difference between men
and women is we're not running off into
the arms of another woman if you get
into a fight
that's true so
but women routinely will go to the
Rolodex and be like shit's not working
out yeah who's next going on
um Nicole do you think marriage is a
good idea today and why
I think marriage is an objective good I
don't know if it makes sense for people
who aren't religious
um maybe actually I mean it does but I
think Prof maybe most people shouldn't
be getting married because I don't think
most of us are mature enough or have
what it takes for a monogamous uh
marriage these days and and not just I
don't mean monogamous like they're gonna
stray I mean just like the sacrifice and
what's required to maintain a healthy
loving uh dynamic in a marriage probably
most of us aren't cut out for it so but
I think marriage is an objective good uh
and I personally would only get married
if it was with um someone who shared My
Religion because it's late for me it's a
spiritual union so outside that I don't
see a purpose uh Jessica what do you
think of marriage do you think it's a
good idea today would you do it
I wouldn't do it I feel like marriage is
a beautiful thing and everybody would
love to have somebody next to them all
their life but I feel like
once you marry to somebody it's like you
they responsible for you like there's
certain things that you cannot do
um
so you don't like the loss of freedom
yes is that so what would the ideal like
relationship look like for the ladies on
the panel because you all kind of shot
down marriage which would seem like a
like I would encourage my daughter to
get married because women typically
marry a Crossing up on the socio
economic scale so they'd be with a guy
that's probably better off than she is
and if it doesn't work out for whatever
reason she'll be financially taken care
of because he's going to be wealthy
right so that's how like Amber's example
of her friend in California who's given
up half her [__] to the guy because he
stayed home or you know whatever the
story was is not that common like most
divorce judges will tell you like they
can probably count that on two hands
that that's happened during their career
whereas most of the time it's usually
the guy that loses his financial
resources so given that all of you
basically said that marriage is not a
good idea and you probably wouldn't do
it like what is your ideal relationship
look like like how would you like I
didn't say that rich
no I
wouldn't okay
sorry Nicole you're right I am I am
actually putting words in your mouth so
I'll allow you to clarify that one okay
you tell me what you think the ideal
marriage the ideal relationship is that
you're looking for okay
of marriage so I apologize
I speak very highly of marriage I hold
marriage so highly that I sang I think
most of us are not fit for what is
required of marriage marriage to me is
very sacred it's objectively good I
think for men and women ideally when
both spouses are functioning in a
healthy way and a truly loving way and
they will the good of their partner that
being said there's a high divorce rate
because that's not happening
um but it doesn't mean that I think
marriage is not good and also I would
get married so I didn't say that I think
marriage is a bad idea or I wouldn't get
married yeah you said like most most
people aren't cut out for it uh you were
talking a little bit about religion too
right with you know the aspect of
marriage sort of tying into that like
they go hand in hand
I think marriage requires a lot more
from people than they understand going
into it and this is something that we
need we should look at before people are
going and saying I do because I think a
lot of people see it as like a way for
like self-fulfillment and for me to feel
good and to have someone there and have
support and have money or whatever it is
but marriage is about self-sacrificing
and it's about your ego dying and it's
like people don't we don't like that and
so if you're not into that why are you
getting married you'll probably get
divorced that's all I'm saying I'm not
saying marriage isn't good one of the
Grievances I notice a lot of guys have
with marriage today is they're not
marrying a virgin right and that's one
of the tenets of most religion is that
the expectation is that she's a virgin
on the wedding night right so that seems
to be missing for a lot of guys too
would you agree
most women are not virgins on their
wedding night yeah I would agree with
that yeah
um so what would your ideal relationship
look like then uh Shania
um if it's not marriage like I said I'm
I'm in it for monogamous and long term
so it doesn't have to get to marriage
um would you like to have kids I mean
you know you're young enough to have
kids right
open to children I mean it's kind of one
of those things that I'm neither here
nor there if I die tomorrow and I never
have kids I'm not going to be
heartbroken and so
um you know if I do meet someone and I
love their personality traits their
values and I want to share that with and
create a person with that and sure
totally
um but
um I don't really like I said I would
love to get married I just don't think
it's unnecessarily good idea because you
can still have that kind of commitment
without the paper if that makes sense
Amber
what's your ideal uh it's not marriage
what does it look like
well I want it aunt and uncle's deal
no I'm married I only have like six kids
live in a beautiful house a giant
Plantation Home the horse driveway and
the lake and all that I definitely want
to get married but I just feel like
right now it's not hard screaming
I'm just being honest like I I just
don't think I
fully have the capability of handling at
that at the moment do I want to be
married 100
but at the moment it's just it's just
not there I'm I think do you have any
fear or any concerns about only fans
maybe tarnishing your ability to find a
guy to marry you
no
it can come across as an issue to many
and I am perfectly okay with
understanding that it was also something
I gave up doing what I do
but to be completely honest with the
right person
they would understand what I do that is
a job and it's just my life
you're not okay with it fine the haters
are gonna hate
whatever but I'm just being honest I
definitely want to get married
I'm at the mental capacity to handle all
that
Jessica what is your ideal relationship
look like if it's not marriage
um a best friend someone that I could
trust a loyalty
um 50 50 and everything I I cook you
wash dishes
I do laundry folds to close
that's what I'm like so so it's
basically common law because then you'd
be living together
yes so it's basically marriage is not
under the ceremony exactly I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out